more now on magic monday as it's been
called and that haul of medals for
team gb three goals and two silvers on
that one day alone and success was
perhaps
even more sweet for tom daley the diver
won his gold
at the fourth time of asking having
previously missed out at beijing
uh london and rio de janeiro uh one of
the first calls he made
was to his uh one of his great mates and
former teammate
tonya couch uh understandably that medal
featured pretty prominently
during that is the facetime conversation
that they've had and tonya joins me live
now from plymouth
where they both started out uh hi tonya
very good to see
so i've got to ask you what what did he
say in his facetime call
oh yeah oh just that he couldn't believe
it he said
he knows that it was so close but he
would never believe that it actually
happened so
he was speechless for the first two
minutes um it was so nice to speak to
him today and he showed me his beautiful
medal yeah well you've been with him um
and all the step of the way i bet you'd
love to have been in tokyo how did you
react to when you
saw that he'd finally done it i know
i wish i was there in the crowd but i
was at home my alarm was set there was
no snoozing this morning i was straight
up
i was on the edge of my seat i was
jumping i was screaming
and then i was crying so yeah brilliant
to watch him and matty lee
did super well today yeah it was a
lovely moment
and you've known him as i was saying
since he was very young i mean i think
sort of six or seven years old you've
dived with him as well
what what will this mean to him
oh yeah it's been amazing watching him
grow over the years i remember his first
competition
he was just a tiny little boy and now
he's this incredible well-known diver
that finally got his olympic guild but
yeah i can imagine he got very very
teary thinking about his dad wishing his
dad was there to watch him compete and
and just the emotions of how hard he's
worked for this gold medal
um fantastic it was just beautiful to
watch i can't imagine there was one
dry eye in that crowd no and it's his
fourth olympics
probably or maybe you know his last he
must have thought
you know he'd never win olympic gold
um i think that's probably what he kind
of thought at the same time he wanted it
that much so that's why he carried on
um who knows what he'll do after but he
does have one more competition he has
the individual
so i can imagine the pressure has taken
off a little bit so now he can go in on
friday and saturday and fight for his
life yeah and a quick word on mattie lee
i mean he gets one of his first olympics
i know natalie honesty we cannot forget
how well he done today
his first olympic games standing next to
someone that's
very very well known can you imagine the
pressure he was under today
and the fact he held it together he
should be super super proud of himself
and something tom did say to me actually
he said that matthew lee this year has
not
been beaten he won europeans
um and he won world cup and now he's won
the olympic games so he has not been
beaten this year
yeah it's quite a night for him as well
and um but for tom i mean what an
astonishing career i was in beijing in
2008 when he qualified as
i mean i can't remember how old he was
but he was very young and the world went
crazy
um but he's dealt with fame and he's
dealt with the high profile
extremely well hasn't he oh extremely
well extremely well he has been in the
public eye
since he won that first um meadow at the
age of 14 world championship for world
cup
and um he's handled it very very well so
hats off to him
and the fact that being in the limelight
all the time can you imagine the
pressure the extra pressure he had like
luckily i didn't really have that much
pressure on me from
around the world and so it was able to
just get on with my thing but
yeah the fact that he's handled it
through each and every single
competition
i can't even imagine how he feels yeah
and eight or
eight or so years ago i think it was you
know he came out as gay which he
referred to in the clip we were showing
earlier and a big moment
for him and i see he said at the time it
stopped me worrying
it stopped me being scared all the time
and it just allowed
me to be me i mean you know him so well
how
big a deal was that for him
it was a massive deal it was worrying
for him of what everybody's going to say
because you know what the internet can
be like lately
um there can be people saying nice
things and people saying horrible things
so i think that was more of a scare for
him
but he had so much support from his
friends his family
and people that he didn't even know so
it was nice that he could do it
and inspire people for feeling the same
way
and i mean just sum him up for us as a
performer
and as a person well a performer he is
like a robot he is just fantastic
every single day in training and
competition
and as a person he's so kind he's so
friendly
i've been with him when people are
asking for a photograph in the middle of
his
meal and yet he would never say no he'll
always get up and say of course even
with his mouthful you know so
he's just kind he's funny and he's
loving loving guy and he's just
normal very very normal down to earth
great and i'm so pleased he got that
medal today
yeah and just very briefly he's won
european world commonwealth now olympic
i mean
just what do you expect him to do next
is there anything he can't do that's the
question
is there anything he can't do but
fingers crossed you never know what if
he became
a double olympic medalist um in 2000 and
already won i know it's two but yeah
well listen tonya
um great to talk to you and um well done
him and thank you very much
indeed thank you